marc levy vous avez vendu 45 millions
d'exemplaires de vos livres
c'est énorme et vous savez qu'à chaque
année des milliers de livres qui sont
publiés pour penser que ça tombe sur
vous mais justement ça crée une
culpabilité judéo-chrétien de ses
monstrueuses que vous me dites et que
j'entretiens depuis 20 ans et vous vous
dites pourquoi moi et et qu'est ce que
j'ai fait pour mériter ça et là il n'y a
pas de réponse à cela la seule
la seule façon de rendre ça d'abord ces
deux
ne jamais se prendre au sérieux parce
que ce serait trahir de se jouer de
vivre de ce bonheur qui vous est donnée
cette à l'âge de 37 ans que vous avez
écrit votre tout premier livre le sucre
est immédiat ça s'intitule et si c'était
vrai il ya une adaptation au cinéma de
steven spielberg derrière de ce livre là
[Musique]
ce déclic là comment il sait pas si
c'est votre fils qui vous a poussé à
écrire mais mais le flash ce virement
pour ce virage professionnel de tyard
chi tacle il est venu à quel moment
c'est pas mon fils qui m'a poussé à
écrire c j'écrivais des histoires
j'écrivais un conte d'enfants pour mon
fils et puis quand il a eu vent il a
trouvé que la télé était plus
intéressante que les histoires de son
père et comme ce moment manqué je me
suis dit bas puis si je peux plus écrire
pour l'enfant rien ne m'empêche d'écrire
pour l'homme qu'il va devenir un jour et
donc j'ai écrit un premier roman en
j'avais pas du tout d'abord j'avais pas
du tout en tête que c'était un roman
j'imagine mm pas le publier et je me
disais simplement je le donnerai un
monfils cathédrale lâche que j'avais en
l'écrivant est comme ça pendant le temps
d'une lecture on aura le même âge et
j'adorais l'idée pendant le temps d'une
lecture des premières amis monfils
images connues en votre tout premier
livre vous parlez il y avait un corps
d'une jeune femme médecin devenu fantôme
vingt ans plus tard dans ghost in love
votre tout dernier se parlaient encore
une fois deux fois on tombe
est ce que c'est un quelque chose
d'important dans votre écriture ce que
vous y croyez ou enfantin mais d'abord
deux fois en 20 ans c'est pas beaucoup
non mais c'est vrai j'ai moi j'ai faim
j'ai plein de confrères et de copains
auteurs qui ont écrit quinze polar vous
voyez où qu'ils ont écrit
donc là deux fois c'est pas beaucoup et
d'argent et cela pourrait être
j'en ai jamais vu donc je peux pas vous
dire oui je suis un anti envoyé je suis
absolument convaincu de l'existence des
fantômes quand j'étais plus jeune
j'étais passionné par sa je voulais
faire des tris pendant les chatons en
écosse pour aller en voix j'en ai jamais
vu et la seule fois où j'ai fait du
spiritisme à faire tourner la table j'ai
remarqué que c'est un de mes copains qui
tablaient sur la table donc j'ai jamais
été témoin de phénomènes paranormaux
mais c'est un ressort de comédie qui est
qui et qui est jouissif parce
qu'évidemment ce qui me là où je me suis
amusé comme un dingue dans le roman
c'est de faire ce voyage à thomas ou
thomas est le seul à voir son père et
donc il a une conversation et tout le
monde le prend pour un fou
notre vote oeuvres le thème du fils et
du père est très important est ce que
faire peut tout dire à son fils la
question n'est pas est ce qui peut tout
dire c'est qu'est ce qu'ils arrivent à
dire là dedans il ya la pudeur donc bien
sûr qu'un père peut tout dire un fils
enfin tout dire ça à chaque paire d'en
décider parce qu'il faut faire attention
aussi à ce vieil adage qui dit que rien
ne pousse à l'ombre des arbres et donc
il faut faire attention à pas faire
d'ombré
et puis la vie qu'on a vécu nous est pas
la vie que vivront nos enfants et notre
rôle de parent c'est de les aider à se
lancer dans leur vie pas dans la nôtre
vos livres sur des tournages et certains
intellectuels vont voler bouder oui
comment vous prenez ça je m'en fiche
complètement écoutez franchement on peut
pas plaire à tout le monde ça serait
suspect d'ailleurs s'est pas blessé qui
moi je prends ça très zen je trouve que
le
le livre c'est une question de désir
d'abord je vais revenir là dessus c'est
très difficile de donner l'impression
que c'est facile et ça veut dire que
c'est vrai en littérature et c'est aussi
vrai en cuisine et plus ça semble simple
plus c'est compliqué parce que là
l'erreur à ne pas commettre c'est de
croire que c'est la fioriture envoyé
quand quand on est quand halak
quant à la finalité de l'écrit on est
compliqué pour moi c'est qu'on a raté
son travail être inaccessible n'est pas
une marque d'intelligence n'est pas une
preuve d'intelligence
ce n'est pas contradictoire on peut être
inaccessible et très intelligent mais de
toute façon c'est dommage parce que cela
veut dire qu'on aura mis son
intelligence au bénéfice d'un tout petit
nombre et ça rien qu en soit c'est un
manque d'intelligence
parce que le propre de l'intelligence et
de la partager que les autres et non pas
de la rand exclusive pour flatter son
propre ego et donc s'ils voulaient faire
simple c'est extrêmement compliqué est
arrivé à croire enfin faire croire
qu'une écrire une écriture fluide est
une écriture facile c'est tout le
contraire
marc levy cette intrusion était du pur
bonheur merci beaucoup merci a vous d
réciproquement merci mille fois